the Philippines leader Rodrigo Duterte
has met with Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu and Jerusalem it's
the first such visit in 60 years of
diplomatic relations between the
countries over the next four days they
plan on signing a major oil deal and the
Philippines is expected to purchase
Israeli arms the two leaders have
already signed three bilateral
agreements that will boost direct
investment and cooperation Netanyahu and
have also expressed their support and
admiration for each other we ask
political commentator amir oren for his
thoughts on the relationship between
Netanyahu and Duterte it's not really
friendship there's nothing emotional
about it it's pure interest Israel SEO
report mentioned wants to sell arms by
energy and while duterte is not held in
very high regard worldwide in Israel
they are willing to accept him and his
reputation should have forbidden him
from coming to Israel but the Netanyahu
government preferred to ignore it when
Rodrigo Duterte arrived in Jerusalem he
apologized for previous criticism of
former US President Barack Obama let's
take a quick listen to what he had to
say it would be a poor break also to say
at this time to mr. Obama that you are
now a civilian and I am sorry for
uttering this words you must be
respected do not just throw away
questions and statements perhaps he
wanted to backtrack because he knows
that he has a reputation for profanity
and for being a bully but in one of the
Israeli television Chan
they just showed something he said in a
closed session with Philippine workers
in Israel in which he said something to
the effect of Obama go to hell so it
didn't really backtrack he just went
through the motions
you